LIANNE WAPPETT: Hello.
This is Professor Wappett
to take you on an adventure
when it comes to connecting
to data using Tableau.
It's important to recognize that
there are lots of file types
that Tableau will take.
And you can see
what those files are
within the connect
pane that opens up
when you launch Tableau.
So you can see that
there's the Tableau server.
Typically, companies
will purchase the ability
to house some of their
data on the server.
And then they can use it to
publish various dashboards
or create passwords for
certain individuals.
So Tableau server is
available, but we are not
using that in this class.
There are also other
file types like Excel,
which we will be using a lot
of, text files, JSON files,
PDF files, which I'll
show in a moment,
spatial and statistical
files, and so much more.
In fact, you can click
on that More button
and it will populate which
file types it can take.
There's also the ability
to connect to servers.
So SQL servers, Oracle,
Amazon, et cetera.
It also has an area where
if you save your data
sources in the
repository that Tableau
is created on your desktop,
then these will populate here.
But these two sources are great.
I use them a lot for demos.
It's the superstore and
the world indicators.
And they're great to begin
to create new chart types
and visualizations and just
get better with your skills.
So there are lots of
ways to connect to data.
And there is also on
the right hand side
here other resources
that you can access.
There's connecting to data.
There's different
kinds of training
that will lead you directly
to the Tableau help website.
So if you have questions, this
is another great space to start.
Let's go and head and
start by accessing
an Excel file, which
is primarily what
we'll be doing in this course.
So I'll just go to the Microsoft
Excel tab and click on that.
And you should
have a place where
you have stored all of the
data for this adventure guide
that you've downloaded
from the Canvas course.
In this case, I have quite a
few different Excel documents
that I'm going to
take you through.
But this one's going
to be just the--
let me make this
a little bit wider
so you can see the full name.
We're going to use the
Connect Excel right here.
This one right here.
So we'll open that
up in Tableau.
Now, of course, you can
always open up these in Excel
to get familiar with
the actual little data.
And it's good to
compare and contrast
as you move from one
data source to another
so that you understand how
Tableau is importing the data.
So here we have a sheet.
So there's just one sheet
within the document.
And it's already been populated
here in the data pane.
And it will tell you the
order number, employee ID,
employee name, et cetera.
And these match what were
the column headers in Excel.
Now you'll notice that there
are some icons right up here
that Tableau has already
given to these data types.
So this right here is
a whole number being
designated as a whole number.
This right here is being
designated as a string.
And of course, you probably can
guess what this icon represents.
But yes, it is for a date.
So this is something that you
can change within Tableau.
So if you bring in some data
and it's not a string data,
it's really a date, you
can select that icon
and change that type.
So in this case, we
do have the date here.
So I want to have that.
Let me just check and
make sure anything else.
Everything else
looks pretty good.
So I'm happy with that.
Something else I wanted to point
out on this particular data
is that there in this data
pane is this connection up here
in the right hand corner.
You have live and extract.
Now, it will
automatically select live
because live data tends to
mean the newest, freshest data.
So there's a connection between
this Excel file and this Tableau
file.
And if I were to add in a column
or rows in the Excel file,
I would just need to
click on this little icon
to update that here in Tableau.
So the great news about
that is that you can always
keep your data working
and fresh within Tableau.
However, whenever
you have connections,
it slows things
down, especially when
you're talking about
a large data source.
So if speed is
more of your focus,
then I would highly
recommend an extract.
And if it's speed and your data
doesn't change often, maybe it
just happens on a
quarterly or yearly basis,
go ahead and extract
the file and then
it will save a copy as part
of the TWBX file total.
And then you will be
able to have a faster
access to your visualization.
So if you keep seeing
that query icon where
it's like thinking
and thinking, you
may want to look back
onto your data source
and make sure that
you've selected extract.
So in short, live means
fresh, timely data.
But slow extract is
a format that you
can use that will increase
your speed and your load times.
I want to share with you how can
connect data using PDF files,
as this may be applicable
to some of the projects
that you're thinking
about working on.
I'm going to go ahead and
just do file and do a new.
So I'm going to launch a new
data source, a new workbook
here.
I'll just keep this one open.
And what we'll do is
we'll hit the data source.
So I get back to this pane.
And then I'm going
to hit this PDF file.
And in those files
that I gave you,
there should be one called
the PDF.WEF_Europe 2020
competitiveness report.
So this is a really
fascinating report.
You could go through it.
It's got multiple pages.
It has multiple
tables inside of it.
I can do a little preview here.
And you can bring that in.
And Tableau will begin
to parse that out.
So let me go ahead and hit open.
And when you do that, you
can identify a single page.
So if you know-- hey, I know
page 22 is the page that I
want to gather some data from.
Or you can just go ahead and hit
Start, which I'm going to do.
And so here can see
now I have every page
that had some sort of data
that could be gathered.
And then I can just maybe
select maybe table 28 here.
I'll just drag and drop that.
And then you can see I've
got various countries that
were in that particular table.
And it looks like they
were all denoted as string.
So again, I could go through
and change that if I needed to.
I could even connect
different tables together
if there was a
common value there.
But that's a great resource.
So if you're working
with PDF documents,
go ahead and have
them be part of--
you can bring
those into Tableau.
All right.
The next thing I wanted to cover
was the ability for Tableau
to clean your files.
There is something
called Tableau Prep.
It is a robust
application that really
helps clean up a lot of files.
And it's great.
But in this course,
we're going to just stay
with using Tableau Desktop
and being familiar with that.
So instead, what we'll do is
we will use this little data
interpreter.
So I'm going to go ahead,
click to a new data source,
and this time an Excel file.
And here, we'll just do
AG connect data to clean.
So I'll go ahead
and open that up.
And what's happened here,
now I have is three sheets.
I've got orders,
people, and returns.
I'm going to go ahead and
we're going to find that file.
All right.
Here I have that file open.
Now notice in the way that
this file has been formatted,
this top area has
some text that's not
related to the column headers.
So there's this space.
Now, what's happening
in Tableau is
that it is going to show that it
has that space by not correctly
having the column
headers that you see.
So here we have F2,
and I've got some nulls
because it's trying to just
bring in exactly the data
as it is.
So it's saying that
this is a space
that they're not familiar with.
And then we've got just the
various F6, F5, F4 headers.
So one of two things I
could do, I could go back
into my data source
and I could go in
and I could clean all this up.
I could delete
this certain area.
I could rename certain columns,
remove some of the nulls.
Or I can just click
this little button,
and it says use
data interpreter.
And they just introduced
this in Tableau
a little less than a year ago.
And I'm super excited because
it does clean up, I would say,
80% of the errors that I see.
Now some errors might be a
mis-marking of the data type
that I need to find
and clean that up.
Or the data itself
could be erroneous,
meaning that abbreviations
were inconsistent
or things like that.
So that's a different
kinds of cleansing
that you would need to do.
But in terms of just identifying
maybe some formatting errors
or some column headers, this
data interpreter and also
the nulls is just a
really great feature.
So that's how you do it.
You just simply click
and apply and then
it's there in your data.
So I want to talk about
two main concepts when
you're connecting your data.
Because most
likely, you're going
to have to connect
multiple sources together.
And Tableau has two
primary routes for this.
The main route is relationships.
And relationships are
rather new to Tableau
as a way to simplify and
create more efficiencies
within the application.
But relationships are
a dynamic, flexible way
to combine data from
multiple tables for analysis.
You don't define join
types for relationships.
So you won't see the
traditional Venn diagram
when you create them.
Here are just four
bullet points as to why
relationships work in Tableau.
It just makes your
data source easier
to define, change, and re-use.
Trust me on this.
And you'll see this as we bring
in different data sources.
It also makes it
easier to analyze
data across multiple tables at
the correct level of detail.
That's what LOD stands
for, Level Of Detail.
It does not require the
use of LOD expressions
or LOD calculations for analysis
at different levels of detail.
Again, that's probably
an advanced use,
but it does simplify
the process.
And then only query data
from tables with fields
used in the current viz.
So it really helps
allow the analyst
to access the tables without
streamlining them and creating
one single table.
So that's good news,
because they're making
our life a little bit easier.
So let's go ahead and
go back to this orders
where we have orders here.
And I'm going to go ahead and
just drag and drop this so.
You see this orange line,
that's called a noodle.
And that noodle
is going to begin
to develop a
relationship if there
is one within the two files.
So there has to be something
that is relational in the two
file types.
In this case, it's saying, OK,
in orders, we found region.
And then in people,
we found region.
So these can work together
based on region, which is great.
Now if I don't like
that, disagree with that,
I can change that.
So you do have an
opportunity to change that.
You could also add
more fields that you
think are also applicable.
So you could say, OK, I'm going
to put customer and customer
ID here so I can create
this relationship.
What it's not doing is joining
these together into one table.
They're going to still
be their separate tables.
In fact, let's go to the
worksheet right here.
And you can still see
we've got people right here
and then we have
orders right here.
So we're not combining
those together.
So that gives you a
lot more flexibility
when you're dragging
and dropping and looking
at different insights
that you might have.
So I could put returns here.
And then you'll
see here up there's
nothing between people and
returns that Tableau can see.
So in that case, I need to
see what fields are available
and if there's fields
that match that.
So I could force a
relationship here.
Or I can say, oh, I recognize
I don't really need that.
So I'm going to just go
ahead and take that off.
All right.
The second way that I wanted to
share with you on how to connect
to data is through a join.
And joins are more static
ways to combine data.
They have physical tables
that must be defined.
They're done before analysis.
And they can't be changed
without impacting all the sheets
using that data source.
So it really does constrain you.
Whereas a relationship can
provide as much available data
to you as possible.
There are times when you need to
join data for various reasons.
Sometimes it's through
security reasons and so forth.
But join tables are always
merged into a single table.
So sometimes you will find that
there's unmatched values or even
duplicates of the
aggregated values.
And so that's some
of the problems
that you might have to do some
more cleansing when you join.
But like I said, I think the
primary reason for joining
comes with security if I
need to hide a customer name
and I've got a specific
ID and I need to match
that with another table.
So let's look at some of
the reasons why joins work
or what to expect
when you see joins.
They are displayed with a
Venn diagram icons so that you
can see, oh, this is a join.
It does require you to select
join types and to join clauses.
You can join physical tables
as are merged together
into a single logical
table, but with a fixed
combination of data.
You, during the join, may
drop unmatched measure values.
And of course, you may
duplicate aggregate values
when fields are at
different levels of detail.
And it does support
scenarios that
require a single table of data,
such as an extract, filter,
and aggregation.
So that's another pro maybe
for an advanced feature.
So there are some good things.
Most of the time, you will
be using relationships.
But let's go ahead and
take a look at the join.
So I'm going to go ahead and
open up a new workbook here.
I have a join example
that I want to connect to.
So we're going to go ahead
and go to data source.
Or you can hit Connect.
And I'm going to go
to Microsoft Excel.
And in this case, I'm going
to do the bookshop data
and open that up because there
are lots of sheets in that.
So you can see there's
several sheets here.
So let's say, for instance, I
just drag my author onto this.
And then also I'm going
to look at my book
and you can see right
there's a relationship
right there that it's going
to do between author ID.
So we have this relationship.
But if I want to add a
join, what I would do
is double click on author.
Then I have this dialog
box that's come up.
And maybe I want to
join author with info
for a variety of reasons.
And so now you can see I have
these Venn diagrams where
I have inner left
right and full outer.
Now I should tell you
that in Tableau, there
is a table where you can find
out more information about what
a left only right only, not
in inner in a full join, do.
But for the most part, I think
I use inner joins the very most.
So I'm going to do
an inner join here.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to select the author ID.
And then in this down arrow, now
I'm-- don't get too afraid this
is more advanced.
But I'm actually going to put
down the book ID plus the book
ID two.
So I've created a
little calculation here
where I've joined
these together.
And so that's how
I've joined them.
I'm going to go
ahead and close that.
And now when I
close out of that,
you should be able
to see-- let me
see that I do have that info
with an inner join that's
been created.
So if I go to the sheet, you
can see that I've got book
and then I have the
tables with the author.
And it should have the info too.
So those are joined
together because those
are created not
individually, the info,
but is joined with the author.
Oh, right here.
All right.
So that's a join.
The last thing that I
want you to do with me
is to do a little bit
of a data challenge.
Now, there will be
class cairns that
will be administered
during class time that
is similar to this format, where
you're going to learn principles
and ideas in Tableau,
in the adventure guides,
and then you'll come
to class and we'll
have you either work in pairs
or individually to complete
some sort of a class cairn.
So this is an
example of what you
might see for this
particular adventure guide
when it comes to
connecting to data.
So I want you to create a data
source using the provided Excel
file.
Clean the data.
Save it for further use.
I'll often give you
specific instructions when
it comes to the class cairns.
In this case, I'm asking
you to connect to the data.
And I provide that data source.
Use the data interpreter
to clean the data.
Now I do have two
bonuses in this example
because I didn't
cover them earlier.
But I want you to
think about how
you could split the
name into two columns
and rename the first one
first name and the second one
last name.
And then another bonus
is to change the price
to be a standard currency,
the quantity to be a percent,
and any measure to a dimension.
So I want you to do a little
adventuring in Tableau
to see if you can figure
out how to do those.
And then lastly, to save the
data so it can be reused.
So go ahead and pause the video.
See if you can do these five
steps, or at least three
of them.
And then unpause it to complete
and to see the answers.
All right.
Let's go through the answers
for the class or the cairn here.
The first one is
connect to the data.
So that should be
pretty straightforward,
where you go to the Excel.
And we're going to
do the AG challenge,
clean data, and open that up.
So once that's
opened, then I'm going
to go ahead and drag my
sheet onto the view here.
And you can see that
there are some problems.
The second activity
you're supposed to do
is to clean the data.
And because it has some
formatting above the main column
headers, it's picking
that up in Tableau.
So what we'll do is just
click Use Data Interpreter
and give it a moment.
And that is all cleaned up.
So that was fairly easy.
The next thing we're
going to be doing
is doing the bonus,
splitting the name.
So we'll go ahead and do that.
So within this data
source pane, I'm
going to go ahead and
look at the customer name.
And you can see I've got
a first and last name.
So what I'll do is I'll
do this dropdown arrow
and then I'll just split.
So what it will do
is at the very end,
it will split
those two words up.
And then I can rename
that to be first name.
And then we'll call
this last name.
All right.
So now those two are done.
And just remember that
you can click on this here
and you can change it if
this happened to be a date.
These are strings.
But I can denote
different values
by clicking on the little
upper left icon or letters.
So then the next
thing is to change.
We want to do price to
be standard currency.
So this was definitely difficult
because it's not in this view.
You have to actually have to go
to the sheet to the data pane.
And if I click on price, here
I have the dropdown menu.
And I can change the
default properties from--
I can provide a comment, color,
number format, aggregation,
or total using.
And I can specify that.
In this instance, I want
to change the number format
to be the currency standard.
And for my version of
Tableau, it is English.
But I could change that to
another standard if I so chose.
So I'm going to say OK for that.
The next one is quantity
to be a percent.
So again, I to do
this in the data pane.
And I'm going down to
quantity selecting that.
And then I'm going to do default
properties again, number format.
And there's also the percentage.
And this is where you can
change your decimal places.
So if you've got
some data and you
don't want to show
any decimal places,
go ahead and put that to zero.
If you work in
specific industries
where you need to show at least
one or two decimal places,
this is where you would go
and you would change that
so that it would be
applied across every sheet
that you created.
So I'm going to go ahead
and click OK for that.
And then any measure
to a dimension.
So that may have been a hint
that you'd have to do that
within this data pane.
So here I have my
measures, which
are indicated by
the green, and then
my dimensions, which are
indicated by the blue.
There are two ways that I could
change a measure to a dimension.
If I wanted to change
customer ID to a dimension,
I could do so by
just clicking that
and then convert to dimension.
When I do that, you see it
goes right up to the top here.
So I'm going to change that
by hitting the Back button.
I want to show you the second
way, which is the easier way.
It's just to click on customer
ID and then drag it up.
And you can even see
there's a line that
says up here are our dimensions,
down here are our measures.
So when I drop that, it then
goes into the dimensions area.
And you know it's a dimension
because it's a blue pill.
As you learned in the adventure
guide, blue and green pills.
So the last thing
that we need to do
is to save the data
so it can be reused.
So after you've done a
little bit of cleaning,
maybe you've renamed
some things and you
want to keep this for maybe some
other individuals on your team,
you can just go
to the data source
and click on this
little icon, which
allows you to save this anywhere
you so choose in your folder
and then share that.
And then that's
the file that will
be used in this
particular visualization.
So it's still a live connection.
I could change that
to be an extract.
And then it would not
go back and forth.
Right now it's going
to go back and check
that file if I were to push
this Refresh Data Source button.
So hopefully, that helped you
get a little more familiar
about how to connect to data.
This is something that
students often struggle with,
especially as they
work with data
that they acquire from the web.
And there are lots
of different ways
that you can bring
data into Tableau
and hopefully you have a
little more sense of what
you can do with your own data.